hey I was gonna brothers today we're
gonna play a game of trains episode one
it's made by telltale game so you know
it's gonna be good and you know it's
gonna be around 2 hours ish
I don't know so if you are free and if
you feel like hey I got a love from
better than ruin my life come on you
click that a pretty pie video obviously
that's the case we're gonna play this
together you and I while I
simultaneously set everything up how
great let's go see I don't know anything
about Game of Thrones I try to watch it
so many times but there's already no
subtitles why is that never a standard
see back then everyone had great beards
those were the days the days I say in
your head horses as friends stupid think
he done it himself the way he tells it
boat Forester sword won't clean itself
you know all right great we're Lord for
is his pitch bad
that's a nice shade of bread heads press
oh okay I select like a damn make sure
it's spotless this time old photo still
won't be happy with blood and brains all
over it gone
it's Holy Blood well it just looks like
paint to me but what a wino by life
there we go I didn't just grab it oh it
goes through the story that's that was
so easy I say that is a friend
and if we're being honest we are Justice
Breyer why not it's honking swords like
that two big farmers have great hair
he was nowhere near the Kingslayer at
the Whispering Woods he was so drunk he
barely made out of his tent next I'll
tell us he caught Tyrion - its what
really happened erm I suppose Forester
not before he dragged you off or across
the battlefield on your face you're
questioning Lauren's honor I'm
questioning Nora's story this grows more
far-fetched their exam he tells it
get elites votes and wine go on it's
your job right thanks welcome great hair
I have to do anyone with great hair I'll
do it
mom's family has faithfully served house
Forrester for centuries his honor is
beyond reproach house Tully is forever
in his debt they've never seen a feel
proud so when that's the day the
Kingslayer dragged poor Noren across the
battlefield
is that a joke that's your call tonight
we celebrate yay even the [ __ ] get to
celebrate it's gonna get me drunk Iran's
march on Casterly Rock and house
Forrester has been given the greatest
honor to lead the young wolf army and
ride as the Vanguard members yes yes so
Victor I won why do I know him from I
swear to god I've seen him yes my lord
there's also the question who wants to
be done with you it's been on my mind
for a while now what do you mean sempai
what do you make you've served House
Forrester well for several years now but
I can't expect you to Squire forever -
shall I reward your loyalty see I knew
he was gonna hit on me for you well I
want to fight me well let me fight for
you my lord you've more than proven
on the battlefield no man would question
that there were those who are here
accounts and your uncle but for your
name is my Squire but you've erased
those doubts entirely it would be an
honor to see you riding by Roderick side
in the vanguard tomorrow not as a squire
but as the equal of any man who serves
house Forrester it's well-deserved
carrot your hard work has paid off
thank you my lord I promise I won't let
you down I mean we didn't clean that
sword once now keep this between us
we're celebrating tonight I wouldn't
want the other Squires to feel
discouraged
yes my lord now go and find Roderick if
he can he's gonna die
thank you he's gonna die and then we're
gonna remain a squire and I'm gonna be
like son of a [ __ ] oh I'm not a [ __ ]
anymore I along with you so I outrank
you
you should help me right right well
that's what you think
yellow bet she may have a fancy haircut
[Music]
let em fetch his own wine for once he's
a drunk liar and an arrogant prick you'd
better watch your tongue boy it could be
much worse [ __ ] do you know about it
nothing is worse in Naurang see that's
where you're lucky low expectations
I'd blown up covered in pig [ __ ] shovel
and slop well maybe I'd think saddling
his horse was the greatest on there in
the Seven Kingdoms
I suppose this beats pig farming don't
get angry with me we're not different
you and I yeah that's right [ __ ] but
I'm not the son of a pig farmer
my father had dignity Oh sick burn brat
all I'm saying is at this rate we'll
never be more than this which is nothing
the lowest of the law yeah if you keep
up complaining line no we could be
Squires for life only flying around a
[ __ ] wedding but a waste a [ __ ]
time I'm sick of listening to your wine
with that attitude you'll never be more
than this easy for you to say maybe if
my uncle were Castell then I feel
different who my uncle is has nothing to
do with it how much further
that's right over there
the twins stronghold of high sells Bray
who the red wedding
I heard her that wait a minute take your
time you lots of drunk your share good
thing Lord Walters in a generous mood
and when our wine tasted back then
phrase you know [ __ ] phrase nice
night for a wedding oh why do they have
weapons ready often he finds it will it
was been for one of his daughters
yeah I don't expect me to carry it for
you son
shits about to get real I've seen this
this is the only part I've seen out of
Game of Thrones
everyone know it's about two red wedding
nomadic to you she got too much wine we
have enough wine take the [ __ ] Flag
it already
[Music]
what's wrong with him salts in the
matter
oh wait we have to go that hat is so I
go off you're in such a rush say Bowen
warned Lord Forrester what about what
the hell was that about
slow down with you run
[Music]
so awkward oh [ __ ] that one oh alright
then when that screams Christ
you need to get back to Kappa oh nice
don't worry I got it dodged it like a
mouse yeah to the left to the left
[Music]
Thanks oh I don't even do anything
click a tease shield Jesus Christ why
does everyone die why is he just
standing there oh god okay okay get it
right get it oh gotta go face
shoot that one no not this one that
gotta hurt
thanks but I'm talking about what we're
gonna do yeah we'll just go straight to
the [ __ ] woods that's I mean I'd
fight like a man
like a true Lord and Viking Savior crawl
forward to safety anyway now I know my
shield is gone what do we do whatever it
is we have to save them
the bearded man side step damn step
clicking boob buddy buddy up an attack
it's a fest oh my god are you kidding me
there's a fake one god
kick him in the nuts
every money it's all good when people
died in so much better ways before
except that good job
oh god why don't you just make out with
him already if you like him so much
[Applause]
he'll game he's been a Asst hey yelped
he dead breath
speak up got it or not uh I tried to
save him but there was nothing I could
do
sorry sorry about that I know what
quickly yes but it's not clean oh wait
it cleaned itself great I got it I got
it done problems no problem bris okay
thanks Brett yeah there's no gold one is
still time how much now is Enid Oh Barry
oh [ __ ] come on bruh
we have to keep moving my lord I hate to
be that guy
well I'm sorry Brett he will tell me to
bring his sword god this with your life
the jelly tie an earth where it belongs
there's no time to waste alright
all the freaks they have to call you're
welcome
I will do as you command my lord you are
certainly well he really remember that I
can count
well not for very long tell your uncle I
love him North Grove must never be lost
tell no one but him
do you understand then give us where
tell only your uncle Duncan tell only
the custom you must do this for your
house go kill the [ __ ] foresters I
mean oh damn daddy's some next-level
[Music]
see he's right there why they can easily
hunt him down how did I make it I'm such
a little fancy god damn it don't dilly
didn't make noise needle his hands gosh
tyranny are there any Vikings in this
hashtag relatable I need to find them
iron from ice episode 1 well they didn't
hunt me down
I guess no one cares about me
[Music]
oh hey piggy how you doing you sexy
beast mm-hmm he does that face mmm nice
eh yes say how to piggy let's [ __ ] him
up a biggie I love sports are you doing
can I can i well I gotta get hungry
sometime right and I walked all night
I said look it up no no Brad you know
it's not a thing that he always does
said [ __ ] face ultimate turtle face I
wish I was an actor's I could just hey
piggy oh the dead piggy what the [ __ ]
see these people know nothing about
survival I can't go back to the other
piggy damn it if you see a flame and
blood just one the 180 and walk in the
other yam look at that that's just what
I would do that's why I massive oh I
teleport cool love teleportation it's my
favorite all right I better sneak up on
this card no God don't tell me his dad
died yeah maybe the dad was part of it
yes are we gonna watch our dad died
awesome
I mean oh my god they're talking about
bacon my dad is a peg Oh God long boy
there's nothing for you here
you killed my father
said move on unless you want to get fed
to the [ __ ] pigs while I'm draw my
sword to kill you for killing my face so
yes you can try if you like have you not
seen my turtle face figs get off my
blunt
this is bolton man now boy the doulton
is the new warden of me yeah Shadrach
and he like a proper lordly so like that
great haircut by the way come on Mike
you've gonna die anyway you don't worry
about it
I'll have that sword boy well you can
have it and a you'll have it come get it
come get it get it you bastard there we
go
well that could have gone better
I have a feeling someone's gonna step in
yep hey what's wrong with eggs you guys
are mean you guys are [ __ ] mean okay
pitchfork or ex pig fork no pitchfork
how the [ __ ] did that hold a sword
oh hey mmm-hmm
all right touch the spirit watch the
spear how [ __ ] bad can it be
how light is good how am I good gonna
give you new your haircut you little
[ __ ] oh I was gonna click in last
second I was gonna dodge you like a boss
and then it just stopped far command
come on so I read somewhere that the
arrow to the knee actually means that
you get married if you get married you
take an arrow to the mean yeah well
you're a dead man ignition
hey you're thinking yeah well you have a
haircut so you deserve to get hang bring
it Britney I have a sword and a turtle
face and I'm not afraid to use it
oh no my dad will die or not anything
you survived Wow Thanks appreciate it
your sister
oh wow she was there all along and oh
she died too
oh okay I tried to stop them yeah well
you didn't really do a good job did you
it's our adventure calling did this and
my turtle face shall prove me prove them
wrong I don't understand why their
family have to die every time they go on
an adventure it just seems kind of
unnecessary and it wouldn't change
anything
it's courage
get the castellón television f you
survived oh that's nice
no one expected me to didn't make it -
thanks guys bring the mr. Mitra in the
Great Hall
quickly wait did you just say master
that's [ __ ] awesome
- white shield soldiers and a Bolton
they killed my family
and for what my sister she she was only
eight years old
oh that's kind of [ __ ] that never
would have happened with the Starks in
power it's unimaginable
unacceptable you have my condolences
Thank You mr. mace tea
hmm the blade cut deep but I should be
able to save your leg wow thanks
your justice was Swift some will call it
vengeance no doubt the Whitehills will
claim it was murder it was your family I
can't say I would have done any
different than you
it was just justice they got what they
deserved
they did indeed we can't let the wine
tales just walk all over us these
maggots ought to help prevent infection
these maggots all the wound open for me
would you
they put maggots in the wounds oh yeah I
heard about that that is really [ __ ]
disgusting Oh
all right then well Oh bro like don't
even bro me oh so how the [ __ ] does
anyone discover this [ __ ] disgusting
greater houses than ours are fallin in
time such as this the late Lord
Forrester was a good man and poor
Roderick a serious man but he would have
made a good Lord our house will never
fall by the gods let's hope you're right
the future of this house is in Lord
Ethan's hands now although he is young
and altogether unprepared to lead right
this might hurt a bit
so how long did they keep the maggots in
there like what the [ __ ] and the wound
shouldn't have been in my forest to save
your life he did odd though did you
chose to save you his squire and not his
son Roderick
thanks thanks everyone keeps saying I
handled himself he was good with a sword
as any man I've seen it gave me a
message to deliver a message about what
what did he tell you get my uncle I was
told only to tell him your uncle
I see must be rather important then lady
Forrester will be here any moment now
I'd like you to walk for me first to see
if you can put any weight on that leg
well I got maggots in my legs I don't
see why not
seriously see a [ __ ] wizard may still
don't stop now it's better to let the
blood circulate you mean the maggots
enjoy it Meggie leg megha leg perhaps
sorry I can't help myself
that's a fine-ass chair back in the day
they had way better chairs now you just
have to have these peasant chairs
wow that was interesting what was the
game won from me here and I'm some the
strongest wood in the known world yeah
you're that's that's [ __ ]
it's like any other wood why would it be
stronger those have you seem to be
favoring it she's sad to see a warrior
lose a leg I'm fine
mr.oat angry look I'll show you yeah
I'll show you misty it's a good thing
you've done bringing that back to house
Forrester by right that belongs to the
Lord Ethan now even a sword as strong as
this would barely make a dent in the
shield like that [ __ ] mama
what am I doing here
it's such a some maggots eat little
creatures aren't they yeah so glad for
modern day the doctor thing medical
thing no you see there you're limping
again oh shut up
what does he want he wants my leg wait
what is mira still in King's Landing I
suppose although I wonder if they'll
bring her home
the [ __ ] is the groin Ryan never easy
being the fourth born son how many sons
desire anything
I suppose Lord Ethan now who's the Axman
Asha now exhale to a source
unfortunately what does that mean
Lord Forrester myself pretends there's
an honor to Squire for him Craig get the
good hey opposite turtle face let's
learn more about foresters on the menu
Kotik thing yeah well um it you do seem
better than most of it yeah well what
the [ __ ] was that
[Laughter]
Talia asked to see you mmm querida I
heard what happened
mmm is it true I have maggots in my leg
you're right I don't water bang so sorry
yeah it's all right mate Oh I only know
them for about a half a minute off to
bed now Ariane
turtle face Garrett was just telling me
how valiantly Lord Forrester fought to
the end even when all was lost
I'm sure lady Forrester would like to
know whatever you can recall it was a
hero m'lady the bravest man on the
battlefield by far he was unable to say
if he's own son he said me instead
because I'm better you were with
Roderick no I'm sure it was chaos and
confusion but if you can remember
anything
I'm sure lady Forrester would like to
know I'm sorry milady nothing could be
done to save him here was house
foresters best
I bet has been so incredibly difficult
for us especially the children but I was
told I was told you were the last to see
my husband alive yes milady
I know it may be difficult to remember
but if I may ask
was there anything he said any last
words before he passed he said that he
wasn't really into you it would mean so
much to the family he mentioned
something about the North Grove the
North Grove what of it
he said no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I'm sorry okay we're back I
don't pick the wrong choice this I am
Jesus Christ
it was house foresters best she's
like--she's mother currently difficult
for us especially the children but I was
told I was told you were the last to see
my husband alive yes I was milady I know
it may be difficult to remember but if I
may ask
was there anything he said any last
words before he passed if I can remember
I guess I have to give this swords the
house first
hey go now we did the right thing it
belongs with this family
Boyd third question of course m'lady
escape their moms a response it's too
dangerous
especially now I'll be sure it's given
to either
Duncan this was our land they were our
people your family I share your outrage
Saroyan I do but now is not the time to
provoke the Whitehills not with Ramsay
snow coming to see us bend the knee hell
with Ramsay snow the daughter named
seams in here Garrett you understand
what this means
you killed a Bolton and Ramsay snow will
want his retribution well he [ __ ]
killed my family needing retribution
they killed my family
yeah hey for what they've done that much
I promise but now is not the time for
vengeance not now when yeah I may be
smart Ramsay snow will be here within
the week and what would you have us do
nothing I would have us use our heads
while they're still attached to our
shoulders
Canada's lost as much as anyone else
within these walls maybe you can talk
some sense into your uncle Jarrod's
suffered enough already you ask too much
of the body deserves to be heard they
deserve to die
all of them yes they we fight ah listen
to your nephew he speaks sense with what
army our best men were killed at the
twins along with our Lord our goddamn
wants to be done ultimately there will
be four lordy so I even ask me is the
boy even barely old a sword he knows
nothing of how to lead me is the Lord of
this house and he needs our help
it's bad enough the Bolton's would have
us bend the knee and swear fealty but
now this well accuse you of murder and
us of protecting you the boy was just
defending himself I'm not faulting him
for what he did I'd have done the same
as any man would [ __ ] the Bolton's one
of them men killed my family by your say
it was justice they'll say it was murder
yeah it's just an excuse Ramsay snow
would need to put us to the torch and
kill us all I'd like to see them try I'm
afraid to risk we cannot take which is
why you cannot stay
cannot stay Duncan
the boy is suffered enough but where
would I call the one place beyond the
reach of even house Bolton where they
may say to the war boys done nothing
wrong not in the eyes of the Bolton's
I'm afraid it's the only solution
fine I'll go I don't care I don't have
anything else anyway in the house so
I'll go I'm not afraid I know it doesn't
seem fair but it is what's best
what's behind the wall settles it well
he really didn't wanted to kill people
oh you can have my horse now think I'll
see you have plenty of food but we
haven't much time
no White Hills will come looking for you
Wow plenty of food how nice yeah [ __ ]
I felt like oh you teleported no I don't
see people can tell him hurt him escape
yeah it's the bed up to me I gladly
drive a sword through Lord Whitehills
heart have given a chance I would
God's willing someday I will of now have
House Forrester to consider first Lord
Forrester would be proud that she put in
the interest to the house ahead of your
own
many of Lord Forrest his best men have
volunteered for the wall his own
great-uncle was a ranger with the Nights
Watch I'll do what's best because I'm
not a [ __ ] Jenny hasn't what's easiest
but necessarily nonetheless I've been
waiting for the right moment to tell you
what what yeah what what is it Lord
foresters last words were the North
Grove can never be lost yes yes still
their duty you caught me by surprise
he said you only tell you you said tell
only you for good reason
Weist don't even know it exists they
think it's just a myth made up by
wildlings and fools real England's
better kept that way
oh I assume you kept your word yes I did
you haven't told anyone else have you
made a [ __ ] please this is important
garnet I need to know the truth of
course not I told no I'm never one
turtle faith Lord Forrester was right to
put his trust in you from this day
forward this will be our secret but soon
I may need your help I can't say
anything more just yet just know the
North Grove may very well be vital to
the future of this house but don't
breathe a word of it to anyone at the
wall but have a helmet Ranger if you can
it will help Thanks how about you help
eh sorry I got a twitch every time I say
[ __ ] there it is
iron from ice and fire from iron from
ice when what that means amber you
represent house Forrester your actions
at the wall will reflect the honor and
dignity of the house I might make you
proud
you already have a home he looks like
that guy Russell Russell what's his name
Russell Russell [ __ ] I don't know his
last name you know what I mean is it him
wait damn it
could we got lame don't patronize me
okay how do I slap it out of her face
was this be safe hmm girl girl girl like
you could have least you know we're not
gonna meet him forever
she obviously months I'm just saying
[Music]
oh I'm sorry look at her she said she's
thinking right now yeah Danny one day
we're not do it now we're at where oh we
choose characters O'Shea did it boo -
Ethan fall Wriston Lord of the house of
for all God wait oh God
Oh disgusting I couldn't find him
could you wait how old is she supposed
to be he hides too well and if you were
smart he would reveal himself why didn't
like this game anymore maybe something
happens to him Ethan's fine I was
forgotten this is a game I win oh don't
worry it's just a game Ryan I don't like
it why not he was worried you were gone
I thought we'd never find you again I'm
right here
and I promise I'm not going anywhere
I wish Mira was here and Asher and and
Rodrick I do too but mirrors in King's
Landing and what she come home I don't
want her to die - Ryan she's perfectly
safe I promise you I don't want Garrett
to die either
my stolen green said he got sent to the
wall I'll miss Garrett here was nice
I don't know what he did to get sent
away like that jared is strong he can
take care of himself
no way to talk about himself this way
must have been serious Ben
I heard Duncan in Saroyan talking they
said someone will come here looking for
revenge everyone's worried about me but
I'm not I know you'll protect us who
said they're worried about me well
Saroyan form he says you can't fight
he called you a milksop oh no he did sir
woodland forgets himself I don't care
care what he says I can protect you
what does melt something I don't know
but I know it's not good Ethan you
should let Saroyan teach you how to
wield a sword like like a man Roderick
and Asha and even showed me how to fight
properly I mean a lord should know how
to fight yeah when those things were the
game Asha it'd all be out here for hours
yeah where was I she weren't born yet
it's so much fun then and everything
changed
Roderick became so serious the Lord in
training never smiled any more
Asha I should just got angry at
everything
I would be honestly you won't be like
that please just be you I like you the
way you are
I know a lord has many responsibilities
but you don't need to be like them I
don't want to get angry but I may have
to father did sometimes but you're nice
everybody says that about you
what kind of Lord is you want me to be
sure the new Lord you can do anything
you want
yeah I suppose everyone will have to do
as you say so I could have all the
sweets I want I'll get with that simple
it would be nice if someone did what I
wanted for once as many as you'd like
yes why not just to be nice
all right don't give me your turtle face
gentle face turtle face
what's the matter Lord Whitehill has
arrived unannounced and certainly
unexpected he's gone demanding justice
car to meet with Duncan he is the
Castellon stay with us please Ethan no
we hate demanding an audience with the
Lord yeah come on we really must go it's
your decision
you are the Lord I will remind you
mine's not a state but is family fine
if that's what's required of me very
well then
is there a bitch-slap option was he
doing why is it going that way so
confused it's a nice vest it was worried
was he doing with this face alright it's
time to be a boss we got boss love going
on here breasts
Lord Whitehill is in a lather I assume
you explained to Lord Ethan why they're
here business with Jared I told him Lord
Whitehill knows Gareth is a squire to
this house or was I suppose is was it
makes no difference the Whitehills were
clearly in the wrong so don't give him
any satisfaction out there you were
decisive and firm now do it again with
these bastards let's not do something
rash things are bad enough as it is what
should I say to him tell him manis men
to leave now is not the time to anger
Lord Whitehill any more than he already
is he's got five times as many men and
the backing of house Bolton or when
you're [ __ ]
stand up for ourselves only cowards and
dead men
oh oh s glorious hair who is this man
reveal yourself
now his hair is hair is too good there's
no way Lord Ethan is it my condolences
for your father and brother the late
Lord Forrester was no friend to me or my
house but to his family it's still a
loss Thank You Lord Whitehill my only
regret is I wasn't there to drop Oh
myself oh I'm waiting for this day all
my life the forest is finally get bird
you my father died a hero fighting for
the north against traitors and oath
breakers I and look where that got him
[ __ ] no bread and salt what kind of
[ __ ] out receives a lord with no
[ __ ] bread and salt
you bloody no courtesies I should have
expected as much bloody foresters my son
white held some bread and salt it was an
oversight Lord Whitehill
I promise it won't happen again not
likely [ __ ] oh no the generations
well now the Starks are no longer around
to have your back are they where the
power in the north now roast Bolton is
the warden of the north
aye and we've been his bannermen for
five [ __ ] centuries you done said the
c-word Lord Ethan you're losing control
of this that's enough Lord Whitehill
I'm not finished maybe if you hadn't
been so [ __ ] greedy with the Ironwood
things would have been different between
us you squandered your share Ashur was
taken from us there's no [ __ ] choice
but to harvest what was left what is it
you want I already want you're a [ __ ]
the smaller knows
better haircut your man the squire we
were minding our own business keeping
the King's peace as his lordship here
said when your man attacked us for no
reason
you're not attacked for no reason
Garrard was only defending himself then
you admit it was your man who killed my
men and a pig farmer at that how do you
answer for your Squire Lord Ethan come
on they attacked it in your name your
men attacked and drew first blood they
murdered his entire family lost pig
farmers not soldiers soldiers worth a
hundred of that chart Oh
you killed my men I know he's here what
have you done with him
I took care of it he received his
punishment and it's done he's gone
what gone that was my justice to deliver
boy and you denied me of it the only
ones needy so Fanjul I have my justice
now bring me the coward who did it or
you'll answer to Roose Bolton what kind
of [ __ ] house is this a house of
honorable men
oh girl the sick burn Bret
lady Forrester you bellow like a wounded
boar Lord Whitehill have you forgotten
your manners I mean no disrespect to you
milady considering your losses this is
not over it's over when my son says it
is
this is over Lord Whitehill Ethan is
Lord of ironrath now by writes his word
is law here if that displeases you then
I trust you can find the door wow that
lad may be Lord of this house Lord
Bolton will have the final say I'll send
him a raven letting him know a forester
man killed one of his own that the new
Lord Forrester lied to my face and
denied me my justice then we'll see
whose word is law
do as you like
Lord Whitehill damn it I could have had
a thicker burn son of a better but it
would have a pretty hairy card name why
do they have those haircuts they're so
ugly I never understand I think we did
pretty good there Brice high five I was
wrong about your son milady
he stood up to him like a true Lord are
ye brave my son but you'll need to be
braver still when Ramsay snow arrives to
see you bend the knee prepare a raven we
need to send word to Meera in King's
Landing at once
that's what you did back in the day
before the Facebook's and the Twitter's
he sends the rapes although just a
handmaiden she has Margaery Tyrell favor
and Lady Marjorie's betrayal to the king
may want to keep the Bolton's of day if
it's presented to her as it should be
what's within like glowy graphics
sometimes it's really strange hey I'm a
girl now hey hey hey they said there was
nudity in Game of Thrones hey hey hey
hey sorry is that okay did I say that I
loved damn it alright what do we get I
should send me this coin to remember him
what a strange place Essos that's why
there's skin it's like oil painting is
that it even made this for me well
that's good to know I guess
man they've bathes beyond our time was
so much better to just kill people and
you could just king's landing kill one I
wonder if it's sunny at ironrath today
see we're really just all violent and
horrible people back in the day we could
take it out on things but now which
isn't is made by man do it on the
internet' miss long stride yeah
I get from more Trek and all drugs dead
so what are you gonna do money I hope to
see them all someday well that's awkward
what do we got here and letter from my
mom whoa whoa goddamnit
but he must appeal to Lady Margery to
intervene on our behalf she is our best
hope and can be a powerful ally
especially now when your family so
desperately needs her help who's there
who goes there in medellín
oh sorry m'lady I I didn't mean to
disturb you I can come back later if
you'd like what do you want
sending me later would be best hallo
lady Marjorie you're early I was hoping
there would be time for us to talk come
there's something we must discuss
from the day you arrived in Highgarden
I've thought a few more as a friend than
as my handmaiden I'm the man in fact
thank you my lady and you know how I
feel about what's happened to your
family I feel your pain as if it were my
own son is beyond imagining and your
poor family as well I need your help my
lady
of course and I will help you in any way
I can but there's another matter we must
attend to first
mm-hmm you must understand there are
limits to what I can say especially here
in King's Landing now that I am to be
queen to have a handmaiden from the
north whose family fought for Robb Stark
it raises questions at a time I can
least afford Circe herself cornered me
this morning outside the Royal Sept
she mentioned the northern girl in my
service has she painted you a traitor
what she was very pleased with herself
I'm not a traitor I think was not it's
only an excuse to torment you and by
extension me she demands an audience she
wants an apology of some sort for what I
don't know but she's waiting for us now
and I promised I would bring you to her
I wouldn't ask this of you if it were
not important I cannot afford any
conflict with Cersei with the wedding so
near I'll do as you ask my lady
I'm so confused you I could trust you
humor her tell her what she wants to
hear humor her are alright see if the
Queen Regent is ready to receive us
what
you'll be fine I know you well you may
order I know her face from but you must
say another
good luck
[Music]
she has such a strange face I can't put
my face on it
no wait I can't good much whatever looks
very kind of dark soul Halsey oh it's a
little guy you can do this Sakai no wait
that's offensive he's cool
all right this poker face just pretend
that it's fine and everything is art
what aren't you looking lovely this
evening
you don't have games very nice [ __ ] with
your permission
allow me to introduce lady mirror of
house Forrester
all right well I guess we'll kneel your
grace she's pleased her courtesies
impressive you may rise house Forrester
is a northern house royal to the king
are they I beg your pardon your grace I
wasn't talking to you I want to hear
from the girl is your family loyal to
the king perhaps you should ask the new
Lord Forrester he's not here is he
she is house foresters loyalty to the
crown never wavers your grace I see and
yet for centuries the foresters have
been loyal bannermen to House Stark a
house of traitors
yes your grace they are traitors
the darks were your liege lord yet you
name them traitor so easily
clearly her loyal Danna Cuevas quite a
lot if she has any loyalty at all damn
it she got me is your house willing to
swear fealty to your new liege lord
Roose Bolton yes your grace
absolutely I see despite the fact Roose
Bolton allied with Walder Frey if it was
me I'd find it difficult to so quickly
forgive the men who killed my father
old allegiances are not easily abandoned
but now that the war is over we must
look to rebuild and forge new alliances
there are ships and shields to be built
and Joffrey will need a steady supply of
iron wood for his armies I'm told there
are others who would happily serve that
purpose but I trust we can rely on house
Forrester Foster Ironwood does seem
rather unique yes your grace
it would be a shame to see it fall into
the hands of another house I imagine you
do almost anything to prevent that from
happening
wouldn't you I was sold and they do
whatever was necessary to save Casterly
Rock it would be unfortunate to see
another house lay claim to what's yours
I won't dishonor myself your grace
she like Dave I see damn it Adam
hey mmm what would you have the girl do
sir see it's not as if she fought beside
the Starks wielding a battle axe for the
northern army it raises an interesting
question I suppose can we truly blame
those who end up on the wrong side of
the wall
our dear Marjorie here was betrothed to
Renly Baratheon on the false assumption
that he would one day rule the Seven
Kingdoms
can we fault her for her mistake should
she be held accountable she was just
following her heart your grace in the
very same heart so quickly led her to my
son [ __ ]
I hope you find it quick now [ __ ] we've
well she can be such a hard thing to
define this city alone is filled with
all sorts of ambitious opportunists
looking to reinvent themselves
pretending to be something they're not
who knows what lurks within their hearts
yeah there you are a girl from the north
here in service to lady Margaery one can
only assume her interests are yours yet
loyalty to a king that must be absolute
beyond question and if your loyalties
were to become conflicted between your
king and the very person whom you serve
what would you do then okay I'll answer
the question go on I must choose
Margaery your grace
I serve at her pleasure
clearly your handmaiden does not have
her priority street she is a threat to
the crown isn't she the most dangerous
handmaiden in all of King's Landing
my sense is this girl will say almost
anything to get what she wants which is
not very encouraging well you have
pretty hair did I mention that I'd like
a word with you if I may of course your
grace aside you can't win it's like you
can't win them one no matter what you
press I tried so hard to lose it I'll
walk you out
well let's this may come as a surprise
but I Met Your father once at the Tony
at Lannisport
even then he didn't dress through his
Bolton
we only spoke briefly but your father
struck me as an honorable man you have
my condolences for his loss these would
be trying times for your family even
under the best of circumstances Thank
You Lord Tyrion that's very kind of you
to say you were brave to declare your
loyalty to Lady Margery no doubt she was
pleased but Cersei she will not soon
forget what you said
it was quite the first impression I of
course found it all highly entertaining
but it certainly wasn't what Circe was
expecting I wasn't trying to please her
I think that was clear to everyone my
sister and I have our differences she
takes great pleasure in her little
charades
I take mine enforcing them we must find
our amusements where we can she
threatened to give your Ironwood to
another house it is the master of coin
who decides such matters the crown needs
boats boats need wood and I speak for
the crown in this regard not her what
are you suggesting
I suppose the crown could be persuaded
to secure Ironwood from house Forrester
lady Marjorie might not look favorably
on such an alliance and it would
infuriate Cersei mother what would be
amusing for me might prove rather
dangerous for you and your house are you
willing to risk that
it may be falsely dangerous in fact
forget I even suggested such a thing
it's a risk I'm willing to take law
Tyrion please you are a brave girl
option I'll consider it
see now if you'll excuse me I promised
Sansa I would join her for dinner
tonight three beautiful bottles of
Dornish wine await my arrival the mere
thought of them makes me thirsty already
I hope we meet again nothing would make
Cersei happier now be careful this is
not the north
King's Landing can be a nest of vipers
to the uninitiated there is too many
names and locations and blah blah a lot
for me to really understand what's going
on here does this make sense for anyone
who actually watched the show because I
were read books of course I wish I kind
of wish I had at this point because I am
really confused if you confuse I see as
a way of looking at me so you're nothing
it didn't go very well
I'm sorry Cersei is known for being
rather difficult you mean a [ __ ] she's
saying that she's a [ __ ]
lady Margaery has spent the entire day
working on the seating arrangements for
the wedding of course you and I are
seated way at the back here with the
fourth cousins and the ninth warm Sun
sir Jaime
I wouldn't mind tarnishing that white
cloak of his what girl-talk Oberyn
Martell
[Music]
I'm told he has a paramour he is quite
handsome and quite passionate from what
I've heard perhaps lady Marjorie can
make the right introductions who knows
we might meet our future husbands
although marrying a king I can only
imagine what that would be like pretty
[ __ ] you marry Joffrey if it meant you'd
become queen he does have a certain look
about him and he's always treated lady
Marjorie well I don't want to be queen
no matter who I'd have to marry don't
want to be queen you northerners you'd
make a perfect scepter well I would
marry him imagine the power you would
have as Queen of the Seven Kingdoms
I might even allow you to be my
handmaiden what a [ __ ]
let's see who else should we marry off
Brienne of Tarth and terian Lannister
what a perfect match yeah I have no idea
what she means by that number names for
the love of God how she's angry I'm a
step I'm sorry
well I'm sorry milady as am i we
shouldn't have been messing about
this is not a game it's a battle plan
allies and enemies can be made with
every moon's yet they say it is men who
are powerful
the Queen was rather disappointed by
your display mirror I'm just glad it's
over
King's Landing can be exhausting
sometimes there's always someone to
please or some perceived slight to
smooth over I fear it will only get
worse when I am queen once I know your
true heart the lords and ladies will
have no choice but to love you it sounds
like my kind love do you agree
it doesn't matter what you feel it's
only matters what you say you learn very
quickly you were brave agreeing to obey
the Bolton's
that cannot have been easy I know you
must fear what Lord Bolton might do to
your family I do appreciate your
willingness to appease her as difficult
as it may have been thank you my lady
that there's been something on my mind
something important what is it I I did
have a favor to ask give you in return
here goes whatever you wish to say you
can say it in front of Sara there are no
secrets between us who made it about my
family I trust her
I don't trust her I prefer to speak with
you alone
Oh Sara Sara you better get the [ __ ]
outta you see right learn how to spell
your name properly too while you're at
it [ __ ]
that's right Sara it's stupid sir
alright one ask if you could ask Joffrey
to intervene on behalf of my family
Ramsay snow is on his way to pine rats
to see my brother bend the knee if
Joffrey could send a raven until the
Bolton's no one at house Forrester is to
be harmed
I think that sounds pretty reasonable
small request
Oh especially now
Joffre knows only too well your family
fought for the Starks and now you would
have me ask him to intervene is the
situation that dire Joffrey will not
look favorably on such a request it is
that tire my lady I fear for my family's
safety
I don't know mirror if Cersei were to
find out
don't let the Queen bully you you have
power over him lady Margaery as no one
else does not even his mother Ramsay
snow will arrive at ironrath within the
week I would never ask this of you if it
weren't so urgent very well I'll make
your request but I cannot promise
anything thank you my lady
I will send a raven to my family at once
since Ravens mane they should have
called it Raven instead of Twitter how
does Raymond sound yeah I probably
wouldn't be a good idea I think about it
Oh back hey that's got some people
finally policy damn you or say well I
like everybody like no don't go horse
all right what's going on here
ooh torture let's play a game shall we
who looks mean did you know my ancestors
wore the skins of their enemies as a
coat see that's where the days he did
weird [ __ ] like that and almost fine
good times if he is he cutting his
nipples that is the worst but he didn't
make it easy with all that bloody noise
rocket Ronin cat never stop that's my
time to say a naked man holds few
secrets but the flayed man blade man he
does now
how much further is it
to these foresters
the table
- it most ah bros that yeah bro like my
nose
Heyman's horsie that
damn horse I know I hit something
stay still on my man they're gonna hug
me down with the horsies
nevermind
we've wasted enough time already
my ninjas look behind the tree
best decision maker in the world baby
pie is it's gonna rhyme something and
then hey let's take a look at this men's
nips not in a weird way of course this
dinner I want to see them being cut off
way
okay the slow approach is gonna jump
scare us I played enough horror games to
hear anticipate these jump skates oh the
what a nice banner hey buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
daddy's ain't see oh no Brad can you
really live that long that's oh man I
took back everything I said as I was
saying you are young and there are those
within these walls who are uncertain of
your leadership yeah well but 300
generations of Forester Lords stand
behind you
[Music]
North go hard the tall who founded our
house and your grandfather Lord Thorin
the bold who seized back the river
valley from the white hills what do they
call my father Lord greater the good
they told me that the end of this
episode is really good some curious and
wise and courageous in battle
I want to be like that like my father
your father was well regarded by nearly
everyone that took years if not decades
to earn these were your father's people
to lead and protect and now they're
yours but your father did not bear this
responsibility alone he and every
Forester Lord before him chose one man
whom they trusted above all others the
Lord Sentinel Forester traditions demand
that a new Lord Sentinel must be chosen
[Music]
hey Paul can you cream it son
ooh I've done nothing wrong
he's only trying to survive Lord Ethan
missed who wins this match this Craven
is a deserter under theme
this house is dude
[Music]
we all [ __ ] know it quiet thief
Eric was supposed to be guarding our
weapons but instead we caught him
stealing them to shields in three Spears
you stole from us I feared for my life
yes my lord I fled we should all flee
it's not stealing if you're taking
what's yours by right he speaks like
family two feet they're not two coins to
rub together since Lord Gregor left us
to rot here where's our pay a share of
bread and wine grows smaller every day
[Music]
but Ethan I know these words are hard
but they're honest this house is falling
we'll never survive the coming winter we
are in this together you say that but it
won't be you starving come winter you'll
address him as Lord
talak him Lord Ethan you must decide the
punishment Lord Gregor always took a
thief's fingers three of them now may
not be the time for harsh punishment the
men are on edge as is need to know they
cannot do whatever the [ __ ] they please
their Lord will not permit it
he can send him to the war
well well well it seems that you made a
little mistake thing for you polish me
you'll be punishing an innocent man -
two - two - two - two - two - three
space will be famous Forrester law
divine rustling you can't do this I
changed my mind
oh god please a chocolate
I'll teach you that everyone's happy
that was have McDonald's come on
that was certainly unpleasant but a lord
must meet our punishment when it's due
not just yourself of course it can weigh
on any Lord it's a large duty so I did
it you heard what the thief said I
expect this sort of thing will happen
again but a Sentinel can help you in the
face of disloyalty you need someone you
can trust by your side someone you can
rely on no matter the circumstance
possessing wisdom but Meister that may
signal counsel is for my lord you of all
people should know that too many voices
muddy the message that is why there is
one Lord above all yeah and so there
must be one advisor above the rest there
are two capable men for the role they
both want the job but neither things
very highly of the other decide between
them hmm talk to them
solicit the opinion of people close to
you hear the bracer of the Sentinel the
badge of office tonight is your first
small council meeting it would be wise
to bestow this bracer upon your chosen
Sentinel then to show that you are
decisive and in control of this house
your Sentinel will wear this for all to
see
I'll make the right choices Sentinel I
think we're doing pretty good here bread
stick with me when you're ready to
convene the small Council my lord may
see me stick do it I break hair I
punished a [ __ ] and we will pick
whatever is best for this house so any
movie story book ever tells me that I
should go with the guy who they Gannett
the night's be uncle the uncle of the
guy but hey I'm spinning why should we
get to play how about that how about
that game play huh let's look at him
that's one fine-ass Pig all that was
very interesting in stock German yes
milord
I have much to consider and face a
difficult decision perhaps I can help
your father often sought my counsel
as Lord I must name a sentinel of course
and if I may ask who do you favor for
the raw perhaps I can share my insight
and talking can sometimes help you make
a decision actually I wanted to ask why
did you send Garrett away I did it for
your own protection milord Garrett had
to go by sending him away myself I
thought it will keep you blameless in
the eyes of the Whitehills
I only hoped to give you an advantage I
understand and you're forgiven
thank you my lord Thank You Duncan I
appreciate your advice I'm at your
service my lord okay so we got some
insight on him I'm going with Duncan so
far because he made what was best for
the house
and what was best for me so I should go
with him am i right sorry sorry okay
let's talk then the Meany pants sir Oh
sir roiland let's look at him but at the
same time I feel like right now the
house is in a bad state in the night
might not necessarily be time for some
[ __ ] democracy I'm just kidding let's
see what he says no sword word of course
ma'am I have many decisions to make and
I wanted your advice
I need to name a sentinel oh you do and
it's good you came to me I know this
house and everyone here knows me they
know I can old the rains or wield the
sword in equal measure I'm the man you
need I might I remind you it was Duncan
Tuttle who sent gathered to the wall he
undermined your authority and made you
look weak to the Whitehills I would
never do that to you
and if you pardon me saying so I think
your father would be proud seeing you
make good choices as a young lord I
haven't made my decision yet
once I appreciate your opinion so when
will you declare your decision with my
lord
tonight
very good I trust your judgment my lord
so I think I'm gonna go with them and
I'm gonna say it yet
you already know [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
alright let's go to Malcolm a mountain
that [ __ ] Malcolm he's an [ __ ]
let's just let's just go home have a
some fried chicken I love fried chicken
Maisie maister maister yes Lord Ethan
are you prepared to name North Sentinel
I yes master
I'm ready very well I will convene the
small Council at once we Israeli breasts
but as youths ready those that is the
question that we all ask myself every
day
[Music]
you may sit I believe Lord Ethan has
reached his decision before I named my
Sentinel I must tell you
Duncan roiland this house needs you both
but you can only choose one my lord let
him be on with many thought either of
you would make a fine Sentinel but I
have made my decision
saralyn you looking fine me me you are
you darling don't
everyone would choose to come on you
will be my Sentinel talk this this is
reckless Lord Ethan has made his choice
yeah mom's I'm sorry no disappoint you
my lord
now Sentinel what do you have to report
of Ramsey snow our Scout sees only a
day's ride from here with no time to
waste
who knows what he's capable of we need
to prepare for the worst we can devise a
plan to deal with him the Bolton's need
our people to harvest the Ironwood even
the bastard Ramsay must understand that
he's not coming here to negotiate will
you must answer with the sword that's
bloody suicide you gamble with the lives
of everyone within these walls
ignore Saroyan you named me Sentinel I
knew this would happen
he cannot be true he's the bloody small
council Lord Ethan deserves to hear from
all of us I will hear from my Sentinel
please sir island is clearly able and
ready to take up arms but the rest of
our soldiers are not we need to take a
cunning approach diplomacy can be a
sharper instrument than a saw the Bolton
sigil is a flayed man force is the only
thing they understand gentlemen please
[Music]
thank the gods Mir has asked lady
Marjorie for her help it's not too late
for the crown to intervene on our behalf
but we must have a plan if Mira's
efforts are not successful I trust
Mira's judgement
I don't doubt she did everything within
her power to help us mother what do you
recommend we do we must give him
whatever he wants and be done with it
it's too dangerous to do otherwise why
not make an offering for peace my loss
here the wisdom of the Citadel we can
give the Bolton's Ironwood in exchange
for their protection you must be mad
it's pure folly to just give away the
only currency we have to bargain with in
north
we will bargain Meister Alton Green has
swayed me we will offer the Bolton's a
share of the Ironwood and we will
promise our people to harvest it thus
securing their safety a sentinel and
Castellon a must warn against this you
may do this for some gain now but in the
end it will starve this house if we
don't there may be no House Forrester at
all if you aren't ready for a fight
you're bound to lose when one breaks out
yeah well we don't have anything has
made his opinion known and you will
respect his decision forgive us my lord
we are of course here to serve you as we
served your father I
well then let's decide how we shall set
the stage for Ramsey's arrival we could
offer him the Ironwood in the courtyard
the Lord making this kind of offer
outright may simply embolden Ramsay
there could be trouble and all the house
will be there to see it meet him in a
hall it will be more private and he will
not have an audience to play against you
Lord Ethan
yeah then that makes it I will meet him
in the Great Hall a wise move my lord
its careless can't you see totally
steering you wrong
that's enough roiland Lord Ethan has
given his command how many years have I
served this house I cannot listen to
that bloody idiot anymore forgive me my
lord but you are not ready to be Lord of
this nicely to get us all killed
sit down at once you wait did you not
see me chop others through fingers
that's right [ __ ] apologies my son but
now that it is settled we know what we
must do
you will meet Ramsay snow in the Great
Hall and we will offer the Ironwood
providing a safe future for this house
and don't worry Lord Ethan I will stand
beside you where your Sentinel belongs
then perhaps we should adjourn we have
to prepare
housed here well you're well you're
welcome I guess that doesn't really
matter
more than you have named your Sentinel
but you still seem conflicted but no
matter what you can't be indecisive if
you want to help this house forgive me
there will always be those who question
your leadership which is why you need
allies you can rely on is that what do
you think all the haters back in the day
Mira has done everything she can in
King's Landing but there are others who
could help us what about your brother
Asha you want to bring him back he's a
skilled fighter what's more he has the
will to fight hunger for it he always
protected you and your sister and we
need all the help we can get yes I hear
what you're saying but I don't care
remember the miller's boy how he
tormented you I wanted to intervene but
your father said Ethan must fight his
own battles
but when Asha sweat he didn't take a
breath
he grabbed the Millers boy by the neck
that was his first instinct I should
knocked out half the poor boys teeth
yeah how is that any better of course
your father was furious but you were in
danger and there was nothing else
Asha needed to know Asha does not
hesitate he acts and we need that you
have many fine qualities
but I'm not like that but I don't need
to be do I know but you need someone who
is standing beside you
I'm trying to do what's best for this
family what this family needs Ethan let
me send Malcolm to Essos Malcolm stays
mother but I can't have milk and bring
Asha back he will not go to Essos that
is the final word do you hear me
I hear but this is a mistakes I wish you
trusted me with this know that you never
stand alone you are a Forester Mira
stands with us and she may be able to
help us yet goddamn everyone is so
annoying like shut up
[Music]
I'm kidding how are those grapes this
chilling so much are we writing The
Raven thing at Apogee K White's look at
the seal
who we just took that in me oopsy-daisy
huh moments are we are we a smile on
[ __ ] - Oh interesting Marjorie uh lady
Marjorie is still with the King I
thought you might want to know thank you
sorry but we were friends Meera when you
dismissed me the other day I won't say
it didn't hurt my feelings
we've known each other for years we are
friends Sarah
truly just don't you trust one another
they don't hold secrets now lady
Marjorie thinks you don't trust me
and she values your opinion very much
Sarah
my lady I'll leave you to talk
but you're right my lady the king was
not inclined to offer help for your
family I'll need this mended god damn it
he said I was too easily swayed and he
reminded me that I am not yet his wife
aya laid his fear for now but it will be
a long time before I can ask him for
anything again
well that could have gone better nothing
I said could cheer him he wouldn't even
speak to me when I left him I'm so sorry
my lady I should never have asked you
for the King's help please don't hold it
against me
Ramsey snow is on his way to ironrath
this is simply not how things are done
mirror not in King's Landing
I'm sorry milady soon I will be queen
and maybe then I'll be in a better
position to help you but for now now we
must both be cautious I must send a
raven I have to all my family if you'll
excuse me my lady but they know where
they're coming already
this is this [ __ ] [ __ ] right right I
don't understand oh hello begging your
pardon milady I hope I didn't frighten
you how long have you been there how
long have you been waiting there not
long I was just passing by when I saw
you emerge from Lady Marjorie's room
okay we'll just spit it out let's enter
I just want you to know I I can help you
if you'd like and your family how you're
willing to trust me I hear all sorts of
things things it could be useful for you
how can you help me my problems can't be
solved by what you might overhear which
is why you must trust me milady you need
allies I'm sorry I I really must go
please don't despair I know people who
boom bada bing bada boom bada boom
they'll be willing to help you in the
morning what is what is that even
whatever they whatever it is that even
what does that mean
pretty sure I like the dress I wish I
had the same one looks very nice nice a
dress - he's like ye look at a year's oh
ye oh gotta go back take a [ __ ] at least
out the how were they walk in the
costumes the same and we enjoyed it he
should be here spine and values pride
more than honor we'll do without him and
without King's Landing I know you'd
hoped Mira could help us but I'm
confident we've enough strength of our
own and it's not gonna go well they're
ready to act if needed our plan is a
good one it will work so long as
everyone does their part thank God it's
a disgusting Pig ass [ __ ] isn't this a
lovely pile of timber not the place I
want to be if there was a fire
No Ironwood is near impervious to flame
my lord
Izzy may I introduce Lord Ramsay of
house Bolton son of Roose Bolton
although a busted Lord Ramsay has the
full authority all right who is this
little boy is he lost may I offer you
bread and salt Lord Ramsay I loathe
bread and salt you look like [ __ ] so
that's you the little Lord the Lord
white all told me you were young please
look at you
a token for the new warden of the north
let me guess Forester iein carved by our
most skilled craftsman Ironwood doesn't
look like much no one can match our
skill is that so yep not bad
Lord Whitehill can you a lot do this
given enough time we could move in
enough time you could do a great many
things but not this apparently it seems
the foresters have a challenge for
something after all
Lord Ramsay we have another gift to
offer
there are several Ironwood groves along
the borders of our land or producing
tall strong trees we'd like to give them
to the crown in tribute as a sign of our
loyalty to the king you would give him
what he already owns
he is the king after all what yours is
already his [ __ ] look at that war forest
Lord Ramsay come out here I can see
what the [ __ ] have you doing
we really must focus on the business at
hand what is it you want Lord Ramsay
what do I want everything
nothing we'll see first let's see you
bend the knee to my father Lord Bolton
warden of the north
words are wind anyone can say they're
loyal I want you to show me
I only kneel to the king is not the
warden also deserving of your respect
but then I am not my father
perhaps that is what you meant to say
yes see he's a [ __ ] traitor just like
his father and brother here's the thing
I don't care about your loyalty and I
care even less about a bunch of trees on
some far-off hill the crown however
wants what you've got whatever you've
been supplying the Starks for centuries
ships shields chamber pots I expect
you'll do the same for us my father has
promised as much to the king you
wouldn't want to make him a liar would
you that wouldn't reflect well on me
you needn't worry your father will have
what he needs that's a good little you
can trust it's going pretty well so far
they murdered a man yeah well they just
did was forest is quiet who did it
one White Hills sold you dead one vault
no you're mistaken that's not how it
happened men are dead how it happened is
irrelevant then you welcomed me into
your Hall like a proper Lord hoping I
wouldn't linger outside long enough to
notice your pathetic little army that
sort of insolence from one of our loyal
bannermen will not do so I've come up
with a solution that will benefit
everyone what defeat him the White Hills
will be taking control of your Ironwood
from this day forward what what the
Ironwood but that is our livelihood then
you'd better well find another [ __ ]
job you can't do that why not you know
something the white hills duct we are
talking about trees you grow them you
got them down we have loyal craftsmen
who make the finest weapons the white
tellers have no such craftsman do you
want Ironwood for the next five years
or the next 50 generations the little
Lord
we'll try this Lord Whitehill will take
half of your Ironwood and we'll see who
fares better but my lord of something is
better than the nothing you had before
to ensure there's no trouble
Lord Whitehill will install a garrison
of 20 men within your walls but ironrath
that we cannot abide Ethan they'll help
maintain the King's peace and make sure
there's no more trouble
this will cause more trouble not less
not for me
you have a man you trust my son Griff
Griff will eat the [ __ ] happen there
you have no right wait else have no
place here that's me
please Duncan don't oh god yes now this
little forest you know frightened by you
Lord Ramsay please and you a you Lord
Ethan's older sister I'm his twin my
lord no we're like the Queen and her
brother well hopefully not just like the
Queen Cobra
I never had a sister always we have your
sister
[Music]
[Applause]
take the wrong
do it again sometime
what the [ __ ] your story has begun even
I just died stab me in the throat who do
does that what [ __ ] ending bruh
Ethan sacrificed himself for us all he
saved
Talia's life no he'll be remembered as
Ethan the brave even the [ __ ] needs a
leader Lord Ethan named me Sentinel I
will lead this house my sister asked you
to swear loyalty to her son and you
flat-out refused mmm ha try'n - we have
to stop them we do not stand alone there
are those who will fight for us those
who hold house Forrester rest of all the
royalties those who will not stop until
Ethan is event until Ryan is home again
our house will not fall we will be ready
nothing comes without a cost my lady are
you prepared for what might happen
[Music]
alright looks like we took the wrong
decisions
51% stay with Bowen okay that was such a
quick decision 30% swirl oil tea to
Marjorie yeah I guess I probably
wouldn't have done that I just didn't
know that names difference
so that's [ __ ] great 20% took Eric's
fingers well that means 80% are a
[ __ ] [ __ ] sorry you and 62% picked
Duncan Edson yeah I feel like that
really was the obvious no choice and if
you did that then it would make sense to
meet him in the Great Hall as
it's my bing bada boom but he's so mean
he's so mean do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do
Oh like it's that dragon lady hello it's
very pretty
Game of Thrones it's episode two out yet
coming soon okay all right
Oh sexy nice eyebrows she looks a bit
like my Chatterjee
not her where she admit the mean girl
where's she
I want to see here hey did you look like
a Minah mightier I think she does
anyway I hope people enjoyed this
episode and had fun with me today not
and then we Dre or anything like that
but you know if you want oh there's six
episodes in this one well I'll be damned
if you want see you next one please hit
that like button and let me know it's
interesting to see what what's gonna
happen next
maybe who's gonna get stabbed in the
throat next time wait until the next
episodes find out stay awesome bro [ __ ]
comes to brofist